scp-173 it's a sculpture so scary that
even 682 feels nervous around it want to
know how to beat scp-173 if you ever go
toe to foot and up with it the first
step is confidence and positive thinking
take a deep breath smile wide and don't
let that big gnarly concrete peanut get
in your head next choose your
battlefield wisely anywhere dark is just
going to get your head twisted like a
bottle cap a bright space with plenty of
corners you can run around is ideal of
course practice helps too have plenty of
staring contests with your friends and
play scp containment breach religiously
for valuable battle simulations if 173
is kind enough to let you pick the
battle we suggest limbo and would advise
heavily against challenging it to a game
of tag because it will definitely win
and most important of all blink one eye
at a time that way you can always keep
one eye on it at all times keeping it
frozen in place now you know how to beat
scp-173 which is great because it's
right behind you
[Music]